[Musica]
Buonasera Buonasera a tutti È un piacere
essere qui
Io sono un business strategist un Digita
strategist che cosa
Che cosa significa Io nella vita mi
occupo di
elaborare delle strategie e dei piani di
sviluppo per aziende istituzioni
pubbliche ma anche persone
E negli ultimi 10 15 anni mi sono sempre
interrogato
su sempre più frequentemente su una cosa
cioè sulla sulla trasformazione digitale
e su come essa possa influenzare e
influenzi la nostra identità La nostra
percezione di noi stessi
e Di questo parliamo oggi noi viviamo
una realtà un'identità
fisica la abitiamo ogni giorno no
calpestabile come dire e poi abbiamo
anche
dobbiamo anche interfacciarci con questa
identità digitale che non è calpestabile
Ma che viviamo sempre ogni giorno e
quindi iniziamo questa piccola
esplorazione l'uomo
ha sempre
cercato di migliorarsi ha sempre
inseguito il miglioramento
ha sempre cercato di passare da uno
stadio nel quale era di conoscenza
quello successivo
e andiamo a vedere perché
ha scelto nel corso della storia di fare
questo E come ci è riuscito
come diceva Aristotele l'inizio del
pensiero articolato della filosofia
nasce da un atto di meraviglia Ciao Ma
diceva Aristotele che noi traduciamo
un po' per far scena sul palcoscenico
come meraviglia ma in realtà trauma nel
greco antico È
un termine neutro significa sorpresa di
fronte a qualcosa che è sconosciuto
quindi sì È una meraviglia Ma potrebbe
anche essere una meraviglia negativa un
orrore è uno scostamento della nostra
percezione che ci spinge a cambiare che
ci spinge ad interrogarci che ci spinge
a migliorare
Questo è il principio del nostro
moto verso la conoscenza superiore Ma
come l'umanità è riuscita a procedere
Beh sicuramente con il confronto con il
confronto con l'altro con il confronto
con la società che ci circonda con il
confronto con tutto ciò che fa parte
della nostra vita e ma anche con il
confronto con noi stessi l'uomo ha
creato uno specchio immaginatevelo ha
creato uno specchio nel quale ad un
certo punto poter riflettere se stesso
uno specchio finito con il quale
dialogare
l'uomo ha creato uno specchio vede lì ma
la sua immagine riflessa ed è lì che
inizia questo questa speculazione questo
dialogo con se stesso
quindi uno specchio che riflette noi
stessi che provoca la riflessione Ma ad
un certo punto
Da qualche decennio l'uomo ha creato
anche qualcos'altro uno specchio
anch'esso
che però non riflette la nostra immagine
Ma la duplica un riflesso un rospetto
che duplica la nostra immagine
Pensate all'avatar pensate alle profilo
digitale pensate all'identità digitale
non più uno specchio finito che ci
riflette ma uno specchio infinito che ci
duplica
con lo specchio finito con la percezione
reale di noi stessi comunque ben
delimitata noi riuscivamo a dialogare ad
avere un rapporto
tesi lo specchio l'altro noi stessi ci
restituiva l'antitesi E insieme si
poteva arrivare ad una sintesi che era
il nuovo grado di conoscenza ma con
questo specchio infinito che non ha
confini letteralmente incommensurabile
come dialoghiamo è difficile dialogare
Perché Se lanciamo la nostra tesi non
arriverà nessun antitesi con la quale
effettuare una sintesi o ne arriveranno
tantissimi caso più probabile di
antitesi
e non riusciremo comunque ad affrontare
la nostra
sintesi e quindi sarà molto difficile
progredire
ad uno stadio superiore di conoscenza
Cioè sostanzialmente questo specchio
infinito non riesce a restituirci la
finezza della nostra esperienza
e abbiamo creato questa dimensione
perché comunque tutto sommato è il
processo naturale della conoscenza
quello che stiamo creando e questo
quindi è un processo bellissimo nel
quale però in questo momento
proviamo dolore e soffiamo anche un po'
questo Nuova Dimensione digitale che
abbiamo creato che stiamo creando ad un
certo punto ci confrontiamo con essa e
abbiamo paura abbiamo paura di questa
nuova
realtà la paura È una cosa positiva
perché crea meraviglia crea stupore e va
bene ma
induce l'uomo anche a
cercare di buttare dentro questa
dimensione
delle coordinate con le quali orientarsi
e quali sono le coordinate con le quali
riusciamo ad orientarci in questo mondo
digitale Beh attingiamo fortunatamente
al logos attingiamo alla nostra
esperienza attingiamo ai numeri
Ed ecco che il digitale oggi
infatti
e questo lo possiamo capire tutti anche
noi questa sera il digitale è pieno di
metriche
statistiche Come facciamo noi a capire
se la mia idea funziona nel cerchio di
amici
pubblico un post no e poi andiamo a
guardare quanti like fa
metriche Come facciamo a vedere se il
nostro sito è fatto bene se il nostro
e-commerce è fatto bene se il nostro
messaggio che mandiamo online è fatto
bene se il video che vendiamo su YouTube
attira andiamo a vedere le metriche
bene finché rimangono come
coordinate di orientamento va bene ma
forse le metriche Oggi sono diventate
qualcosa di più questi numeri queste
statistiche sono diventate qualcosa di
diverso
vi racconto un episodio
tanti anni fa quando ero giovane ed era
un giovane hard director in un'agenzia
di comunicazione a Milano facevamo
spot televisivi Shooting internazionali
campagna advertising e avevamo bisogno
di modelle o modelli
attori attrici e quindi chiamavamo
l'agenzia di modelle che ci forniva
puntualmente i composit questi fogli A5
con la foto del modello della modella
con le misure standard e poi giravamo
c'era altre fotografie e noi chiamavamo
facevamo il casting oggi lo sapete
quello che succede se uno chiama
l'agenzia di modelli succede la stessa
cosa ma c'è una nota in più in ogni
email se non addirittura nel composit
l'agenzia di modelle si premura di
comunicarci
quanti follower o quanti seguaci Quanti
fan ha nei social questa persona quanto
performa a livello social
se anche in quella foto ci fosse un
pupazzo noi saremmo
invitati a prendere questa questa
modella questa persona questo pupazzo ha
e ha
convogliarlo all'interno del nostro
progetto
quindi che cosa è successo capite che
c'è qualcosa che non funziona Che cosa è
successo È successo che la quantità
delle metriche la quantità è diventata
la percezione e la misura del nostro
della nostra qualità in certi ambiti la
misura del nostro valore e questo che
cosa ci porta a fare ci porta a
comunicare sempre di più noi stessi per
affermarci in questa nuova identità
digitale quindi ecco che comunichiamo
iniziamo a produrre contenuti contenuti
per fortuna non è più così
ma all'inizio fino a qualche anno fa Se
vuoi essere presente nei social almeno
un video al giorno un video a settimana
almeno tre o quattro foto su Instagram
al giorno
12 Twitter al giorno ci sono profili
tweet con 40 50.000 tweet roba pazzesche
capite bene che i contenuti e le
metriche sono delle trappole
chiaramente sono delle trappole e non
solo ma questo modifica ecco qui la
percezione l'identità personale ma
questo modifica anche il nostro modo di
comunicare il modo di strutturare il
pensiero
i contenuti devono essere non solo
devono essere prodotti in grande
quantità ma devono anche essere
virali e dobbiamo scrivere in modo tale
che siano veloci virali trasmissibili e
quindi
destrutturiamo il contenuto grandi
concetti li riduciamo a pochi punti
i cinque modi per essere più bello le 25
fotografie che più belle della penisola
italiana cliccate
destrutturiamo e ricostruiamo in un modo
superficiale Questa è una vera e propria
trappola dei contenuti
Questa è un modo distorto di percepire
il nostro allineamento tra l'identità
calpestabile fisica analogica vera con
l'altra tanta vera ma non calpestabile
di identità digitale dobbiamo allinearci
dobbiamo imparare ad allinearci
mentre salivo le scale pensavo a delle
parole di Fabrizio De André Sì dobbiamo
evitare di diventare Quei mostri pieni
di razza Cina da una parte e distinto
dall'alta quelle che lui chiamava un
cinghiale laureato in Matematica Pura
sta succedendo questo dall'altra le
metriche dall'altra l'istintività del
like posso su una foto Ecco dobbiamo
equilibrarci e quindi come si fa
come ne usciamo da questa cosa Io non ho
nessuna verità in tasca da regalare
e probabilmente quello che dico stasera
Tra qualche mese tra qualche anno sarà
falso sarà scorretto perché è giusto che
sia così l'identità soprattutto
dell'Italia cambierà però
qualche piccola
indicazione qualche piccola visione nel
vero spirito Ted ve lo voglio dare
dobbiamo riappropriarci di un paio di
concetti
Il primo è quello della lentezza
lentezza dobbiamo dilatatare i tempi
dobbiamo
far sì che i nostri messaggi non siano a
breve tempo a breve termine il like la
foto subitanea
Dobbiamo iniziare a ragionare con la
parte non istintuale dell'altro non
dobbiamo eccitare una risposta veloce
dell'altro dobbiamo invece imparare a
concepire il tutto come un dialogo
dobbiamo imparare a concepire il tutto
come un messaggio circolare come un
qualcosa che si attacca prima e poi si
attacca dopo ad un grande flusso di
coscienza e di coscienza dobbiamo
imparare a provocare no l'istintualità
dell'altro l'istintività dell'altro
bensì la ragione dell'altro
dobbiamo non
dilatare i tempi la lentezza dobbiamo
avere il tempo non di aspettare un like
ma di aspettare una risposta ai nostri
contenuti sono due concetti
profondamente diversi
l'ultima parola e poi vi lascio
è
la leggerezza
uno dei pochi autori che ho frequentato
costantemente
negli ultimi anni
insieme a Flaiano è stato anche Italo
Calvino che ha scritto delle pagine di
letteratura e di saggistica memorabili
fantastiche
in particolare il suo ultimo libro
lezioni americane che
è stata la sua ultima opera tant'è che
non è ancora finita Non l'ha finita
perché è morto prima di completarla
lezione americana contiene un capitolo
stupendo la leggerezza la leggetelo
se non l'avete fatto e ci introduce a un
bellissimo Concetto per affrontare o per
mettere nella giusta prospettiva tutto
questo
cioè allineare la nostra identità
personale
fisica quella digitale dobbiamo
riappropriarsi del concetto di
leggerezza ma non quella leggerezza come
diceva Paul Valery di una piuma sperduta
nel nel cielo che vaga senza meta ma
forse quella di un uccello di una
rondine che
sa da dove viene sa quello che sta
facendo mentre vola e sa dove sta
andando cioè quella leggerezza fatta di
responsabilità
determinazione e precisione nel
messaggio che vogliamo dare quella
leggerezza che ci consente di scaricare
a terra di tagliare via di abbandonare
tutti quei pesi in eccesso le metriche
contenuti tutto
tutto questo quella leggerezza che ci
consente di vivere a pieno La nostra
identità sia digitale sia personale
privata di allinearle e In definitiva
quella leggerezza che ci consentirà di
vivere a pieno quello che comunque sarà
un bellissimo Rinascimento digitale
Grazie
[Applauso]